nvidia just dropped a huge tease that
makes it almost certain that 26 is
coming really soon so how would that
affect the pricing of ten to reach
abused
[Music]
welcome to Haris hobbies so if it still
isn't painfully obvious as twenty series
coming really soon
here are the biggest clues from Nvidia
STIs starting off we see a new strategy
saying inspired by gamers built by
Nvidia so this new GPU is obviously for
gamers and we may even see official
support for custom look cocoon
especially considering that AMD
implemented water cooling in their high
level Vega GPUs also we are definitely
seeing ray tracing support at least for
the higher level cards on the t's we see
a person called roy TX texting someone
and is obviously is alluding to our TX
or ray tracing technology and asked for
the release date it is coming really
soon we get the coordinates of Gamescom
which is only four days away on August
20th 2018 followed by it ready in
Spanish and then we see the same person
roy TX another conversation with a guy
named not 11
this guy says give me 20 minutes and
this is clearly conveying that the new
series is not going to be called the 11
series but a 20 series at the very end
when the date comes up for August 28
2018 you pay close attention the first
four digits come up or actually 2080 so
it is really clear that it is going to
be called a 2080
it's going to have great tracy
technology and it's going to be
officially revealed on August 20th at
Gamescom
so no more rumors as official as it can
get before the actual reveal as for Tim
Siri surprising a lot of people are
suggesting that the eleventh series will
be a lot more expensive than what the
ten series launched for so that video
will be able to get rid of all the temp
series GPUs if they have an access
inventory but I really don't agree with
this statement especially considering
how cheap ten series cars are right now
right now you can get a 1080 for four
hundred and thirty dollars four hundred
and forty dollars and there are several
offers in the fourth
50s and over 90% of the offers part
below $500 and considering at the MSRP
of the GT x 1080 was officially $700
this is a really great deal ask for a
1080p eye you can get it for as low as
630 dollars and there are plenty of
offers in the mid 600's and it won't be
long before the 1080i reaches to sub 600
mark a lot of you guys are suggesting at
the 1080 and 1080 TI are exceptions to
the GPU pricing and the other cards are
still really inflated however there is a
clear explanation as to why that is and
it is because a 20 80 is going to be the
first card that comes out and it
directly competes with the 1080 and
1080i due to its closest proximity
retailers are trying to get rid of it as
soon as possible just because the 20 80
comes out doesn't mean that people who
are buying the 10 60 are gonna go and
buy that instead however a person buying
a 1080 and especially a person buying
1080 I will definitely conserve by the
20 80 instead there is going to be a
couple week break between each 20 series
card release and so we won't be seeing
the 2060 till late September or early
October and as those new 20 series cards
come out they're cursed by intense
series GPU prices will drop also it is
not even like the other cards are
unreasonably priced there are plenty of
offers for the 1066 gigabyte card in the
upper mid 200s and consume the MSRP is
$300 it's not that bad also the 20
series has only been teased so far
imagine when it is officially revealed
and launched if the 20 series is
official people will be much less likely
to buy 10 serious cards and as a result
retailers would price of 10 series cards
have much lower prices in the attempt to
persuade customers to still buy the
tensor is cheap use so don't find yet
and expect some huge price drops to come
really really soon for example the 1080i
should be in the 500s the 1080 should
easily go to 400 and be for the high 300
mark and then ask for the 1070 it'll
probably adopt her load 300 plate
frequency at 1070 I really recommend
that you just go ahead and buy a 1080
price difference is just not worth it to
step down to attend 70 and not buy a
1080 instead finally the 10 60s should
go to the low 200s and lastly as for the
ten 50s I really just don't think you
should buy at ten fifty currently
because the tensor is almost outdated
you're buying one of lowest level cars
offered from that as a result I honestly
believe it 11 Series pricing would be
identical or at least very close sir
price of 10 Series at launch if anything
it will be up to a $50 premium over the
10 series due to the new GT dr6 memory
and rate racing technology that's really
pretty much it
also there is already a huge price
premium for the 20 Series even if the 20
series launches for the same MSRP as a
10 series for example by the time of
2080 releases the 1080 TI will most
likely be offered for about 550 dollars
and after 28 releases for the same MSRP
as a 1080 for $700 that is 25 percent
premium over the current flagship to
1080 TI
however the 20 80 will only provide
about 10% more performance in the 1080p
I so there's like a 50% premium right
there and so all are not for the faint
of heart
and only for the people who want the
best tech available so there's really no
reason to jack up pricing even more and
this is just a mainstream series and
NVIDIA knows that and I really doubt
they'll blow it up even more than what
it actually is but that's what I think
what do you guys think how low do you
think Tim series GPUs will go and how
much do you think the 20 series will
launch for make sure comment down below
what you guys think because I do read
all my comments I'm curious as to what
you guys think - make sure to post your
thoughts also if you guys like this
video make sure to like and consider
subscribing if you like to see more
videos just like this one but until then
I'm Hari
I'll see you guys on the next one